sehr hüb kommt aus der Wirtschaft und er
ist gewohnt in der Bilanz anzuschauen
und die Bilanz hat aktiver und passiver
und der Staat hat auch aktiv am passiver
aber er stellt keine Bilanz auf es gibt
in einigen Bundesländern es gibt auch
Gemeinde eben es gibt nicht auf
Bundesebene hätte der Staat eine
ordentliche Bilanz aufgestellt letzten
Jahr und hätten wir zwei Dinge gesehen
zum einen dass die Aktivierung aktiver
abgewirtschaftet wurden Schlaglöcher etc
drauf ein Autobahnen was weiß ich zu
schreiben
geguckt hätten wir gesehen der Staat
gibt immer ein Versprechen hier gar
nicht finanzieren
zu denn da sind Sie mittendrin in ihrem
Thema der Stadt dem geht's gut und den
den Bürgern genau
die Politiker machen nichts draus ich
muss den Punkt mal ganz kurz vielleicht
erläutern also der deutsche Staat hat
genug Geld seit Jahren nimmt uns der
Staat immer mehr Geld ab und zwar nicht
nur absolut relativ so
Wirtschaftsleistung und gleichzeitig
haben die Politiker massiv Geld gespart
weil die Zinsen gesunken sind das heißt
sie hatten Hunderte von Milliarden sind
Ersparnis was haben sie gemacht sie
haben die Infrastruktur verfallen lassen
sie uns Bildungswesen verfallen lassen
wir haben keine Digitalisierung sie
haben bei den Mobilfunk Option daher
kommt es übrigens mal die Einnahmen
maximiert und haben nicht sichergestellt
dass es keine Funklöcher gibt und
gleichzeitig haben sie im Prinzip Konsum
gemacht Konsum gemacht und jetzt geht's
weiter jetzt kommt dieses Jahr heute und
wir haben die Wirtschaftsweise kommen
und sagen dem Start geht super Gutachten
steht drin dass die Schulden des Staates
in Deutschland relative
Wirtschaftsleistung in diesem Jahr
sinken werden warum werden die sehen
wegen der Inflation weil die
Wirtschaftsleistung monginal im Geld
hoch geht wir alle wissen es geht nicht
richtig hoch
Illusion geht hoch die Folge ist die
Schuldenquote geht runter die Verlierer
sind die anderen der Staat ist ein
inflationsgewinner und die Verlierer
sind die Bürger und die Bürger alleine
die Sparer haben viele Milliarden
verloren dieses Jahr nicht Inflation
4.700 € pro Kopf die Leute die Häuschen
gekauft haben verlieren weil die Zinsen
steigen und die hausaufreise
runterkommen das heißt wir haben das
Phänomen der Staat wird immer reicher
und die Bürger werden immer ärmer und
dann kommen noch was dazu wir sind
verglichen zu den Italienern zum Spanier
zu den Franzosen relativ zur
Wirtschaftsleistung und Europa und was
machen unsere Politiker und was sagen
andere Gutachten die gesagt hat der kein
Problem hatte wir müssen die Steuern
erhöhen und da frage ich mich habt ihr
sie eigentlich noch alle vor allem
Facharbeiter wollen wir anwerben was man
Ausland wir haben Ausland ist und guckt
wo kann ich hingehen der geht bestimmt
nicht in das Land in der höchsten
Abgaben lassen das heißt der Staat muss
auf die Diät gesetzt werden damit die
Politiker gezwungen sind
mal richtig zu handeln die Politiker
haben
Diät gesetzt werden
die gesamtverstellung haben gesagt
Steuererhöhung sondersodium was weiß ich
völlig völliger Quatsch aber völliger
Quatsch kalte Progression muss ich
bereinigt werden hier der Facharbeiter
der bei Porsche am Band steht der hat
dann ähm 300 € mehr Gehalt weil die
Inflation höher ist und davon nimmt der
Status weil die sachverständlich hat er
gesagt alles nicht machen
der Staat braucht nicht mehr Geld der
Stapler bessere Politiker sorry auf der
Ebene des Bundes definitiv die sagen
moment mal wir machen nicht das nächste
schöne Gesetz mit großen Sozialleistung
und ähnlichem sondern wie investieren in
die Zukunft des Landes und wir haben die
Zukunft des Landes haben wir eigentlich
abgewirtschaftet und er hört sich
richtig gesagt hat und das ist nicht nur
die jetzige Regierung ganz klar zu sagen
das waren seit 20 Jahren hat man
Konstanz gelebt und jetzt kommt die
Rechnung und jetzt brauche ich gesagt
habe wir bräuchten jetzt ideologische
Akteure die sagen wer sind denn die
besseren Politiker sie oder wer ist denn
normal
beantragen
okay ich nenne ihn keinen Namen ich bin
eine andere Antwort wir haben die
Politiker die wir verdienen warum weil
wir die Politiker mit ihren Geschichten
über schlechten Politik durchkommen
lassen ich wollte wissen wenn sie
verbessert werden wenn wir ich möchte
meine Aufgaben sind ganz andere ich
möchte dass die Leute im Fernsehen
zuschauen dass sie sagen moment mal ich
habe einen Abgeordneten ich würde gerne
Lösung ich bin jemand der gerne lösen
ja sehen die Figur sie kritisieren das
ist ja relativ einfach was sie tun ja
das ist auch populistisch alles was in
Deutschland ich komme viel in der Welt
rum ich kann Ihnen sagen dass in anderen
Ländern genauso Probleme bestehen wie in
unserem Land genau
ich habe insgesamt den Eindruck dass
Leute wie Sie und andere auch Experten
die ich sehr schätze sie sind ein kluger
Mann ja sie schildern Probleme die sind
übrigens überall gibt wir haben gerade
ein ganz über Frankreich geredet ja so
die gibt's überall und ich frage dann
kannst ganz konkret wenn sie immer sagen
die Politiker dann sagen Sie mir doch
mal welche Politiker besser sind
sie haben gesagt das besser machen kann
von Rentensystem ich mache das kurz aber
das ist ganz klar wenn sie jetzt fragen
von den Parteien im Bundestag tut mir
herzlich mir fällt keiner ein also seine
neue Partei nein nein ich möchte mich
schon gerne beantworten werden kommen ja
von der Wirtschaft und da labern wir
nicht sondern wir machens ich möchte
Ihnen gerne beantworten in der wenn sie
sehen die Bundesregierung bzw Bundestag
wo man haben sind die Hälfte ja nicht
gewählt worden vom Volk sondern von den
Parteien bestimmt worden also meine
richtige Politiker sind die vom Volk
gewählt werden die würde ich gerne haben
denn heute ist ja so du musst ja immer
wieder nicht so eine Partei sein um eine
gute Funktion beziehungsweise
Nominierung zu haben das müssten wir
abschaffen deshalb habe ich eine neue
Partei gegründet wo ich gesagt habe SPD
überhaupt nein Entschuldigung die SPD
Schröder und ich wir hätten ja wir haben
vieles erreicht vergessen aber ich sie
haben mich gesagt und jetzt werden
selber ganz kurz ähm und darum sage ich
sie haben eine Frage gestellt die habe
ich gerne beantwortet und davon bin ich
überzeugt und jetzt gebe ich mir eine
andere Antwort
ich kann doch nicht sein dass die
Politiker sagen wir haben
Fachkräftemangel und schauen gucken und
jetzt nach außen außen wo können wir
Leute gewinnen für Deutschland und die
eigene Leute also Jugendliche Kinder die
werden vernachlässigt das sind Potenzial
ich habe so viele Jugendliche die die
eine die die eine Perspektive haben
wollen und die verlieren wir und da sage
ich da brauchen wir gerne Politiker die
sagen ich will dass unsere eigene
Jugendliche eine Perspektive bekommen
allein im Bildungssystem gibt es eine
Ungerechtigkeit da können sie sich nicht
vorstellen und hätte ich die also die
lernstiftung ich habe jetzt 300 ja wir
haben jetzt vergrößert noch mal um
dreimal so großer immer mehr Kinder
kommen warum kommen die Kinder zu mir
warum kommen Sie nicht zu den
staatlichen Schulen da sage ich ganz
offen damit unsere Probleme und wenn man
jetzt nicht laut sind und klar sind und
sagen liebe Politiker es kann nicht sein
dass ihr ständig gewählt wird allen von
den Parteien nicht vom Volk die müssen
wir immer wieder so sehen
nein wir müssen die Parteien müssen wir
einfach klar und deutlich die Macht
entfernen lassen sondern das Volk muss
wieder das Sagen haben der erste
Wahlkampfrede Bürgerbewegung für
Fortschritt und wandelt sehen wir die
dann bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl
jetzt weiß ich nicht weil ich gerade vor
Ort wie sie oder wie du es gesagt hast
ich glaube jetzt ein Boxkampf jetzt
gegen franca wegen meine lernstiftung
ich kämpfe jetzt gegen Tyson noch Ende
nächstes Jahr ähm weil ich das iPhone
für wichtig finde dass
ältere Menschen wie ich mit 60 ja ja
mein Gegner
warum mache ich das alles um den
Jugendlichen um euch alles zu sagen
zeigen mit 60 bist du nicht am Ende
sondern mit 60 fühle ich mich erst
richtig wohl das Leben an und mit 60
fängt glaube ich auch europäischen
Ländern
aber glaube ich eher Steuersenkungen
also quasi dafür Entlastung nicht über
entlastungspakete sondern wie ist es mit
Leuten die zum Beispiel es gibt auch
Krisengewinner es gibt ja Unternehmen
die sogenannte übergewinne jetzt haben
damit sie nicht ja
breite Schultern gut ich glaube der
Punkt ist einfach wir brauchen Umbau der
Steuersystems also man kann sicherlich
muss man diejenigen der Arbeit entlasten
das wollen wir definitiv machen man kann
darüber sprechen ob man Vermögen höher
belastet und so weiter aber nicht
einfach im Sinne von wir machen das und
top soll System oben um einfach Arbeit
attraktiver zu machen das ist im Prinzip
der Kern da kann man die Hilfe
nachdenken wir müssen auch die Frage
aufwerfen warum müssen wir immer in
Europa der Zahlmeister sein die Frage
kann man natürlich auch aufwerfen weiß
nicht irgendwelche richtig ist wer die
Italiener von mehr Vermögen haben warum
haben wir eher eigentlich ein Thema wie
machen wir mehr viel deutsche Vermögen
da dazu gehört es den Leuten mehr Geld
in der Tasche zu lassen aber dazu gehört
auch die Vermögensbildung zu erleichtern
schauen sie wenn sie sparen sie sollen
sie diesen sparen sie wollen Familie
gründen sie wollen recht nennen
Eigentümer werden dann müssen schon die
unterwerfsteuer anschauen
hören die das sind da müssen wir 1000
Euro in Berlin hat mal gerade gibt es
eine durchschnittliche Berliner muss
glaube ich 10 Jahre alleine für die
Grunderwerbsteuer und gleichzeitig die
Zahl der Multimillionäre Verantwortung
der umfahrten ja das kann man das kann
man so argumentieren du willst natürlich
einsehen ob wir wer die Frage ist haben
wir ungewöhnlich viel reiche also sind
gibt es bei uns sind bei uns die Reichen
reicher als in Italien Frankreich
Spanien das ist nicht so unsere reichen
sind nicht reicher so wir haben Wasser
und nicht mit den reichen
nein weil das Problem der Armen lösen
sie nicht wenn sie reichen fehlt wenn
Sie den Reichen das wenn wir mal sehen
wenn Sie die 50 reichsten Deutschen
eignen das ist ein Bundeshaushalt das
ist nach einem Bundeshaushalt reden
jeder Bürger in Deutschland bekommt
65.000 Euro vom Staat in ein
alterssicherungskonto und dieses Geld
legt deutsche Staat der nicht der nicht
der Scholz selber Gottes willen sondern
Fachleute Profis so an wie das in
Norwegen machen global angelegt in
Wertpapieren Infrastruktur global die
haben 8% Rendite pro Jahr und nach wenn
dann jemand 65 ist dann bekommt dieses
Geld ausgezahlt als Zusatz für seine
Rennen aber für alle Frauen und dann
können sie hingehen können sagen dass
sie
Einkommen nehmen Sie 5000 € besteuern
wieder einmal nicht weg das kann man
auch machen
eine Möglichkeit ihre Kundschaft
brauchen
natürlich nicht und das ist ja der
Klassiker jetzt das ist ein Vorschlag
der hört sich jetzt erstmal gut an ich
kann mich erinnern von ein paar Wochen
also diese 300 € pauschal dabei die
Kritik an den Politikern war die Kritik
gießkannten Prinzip das genau das
gleiche ist kein Prinzip also was ich
merke egal was in Deutschland passiert
wir sind hinten die mecker Nation Nummer
da sind immer kluge Leute wieder dr
Stelter jetzt dieses haben dann
Vorschläge kritisieren dann z.B das
gießkrank Prinzip bei den 300 €
pauschalen ist für die Bürger gegeben
hat schlägt aber gerade für 25000 € auch
in gießkannten Prinzip doch sie haben
sie gerade 300 € aber
wir müssen aber sie geben mir doch recht
das in der öffentlichen Diskussion die
300 € extremst kritisiert worden sind
weil man argumentiert hat dass das viele
Menschen gar nicht brauchen und nicht
bei denen man muss normalerweise aber so
das gießkannt im Prinzip ist ein Prinzip
was den Politikern vorgeworfen worden ja
und mir geht's um folgendes das heißt
sie sagen kommen
klingt ja alles toll klingt dafür auch
viele applausen verkaufen auch toll
Bücher aber es keine Lösung für
gesellschaftliche Probleme das sind
populistische Sprüche damit kommen wir
aber nicht weiter weiter kommen wir nur
damit wenn wir uns den Dingen stellen
und wenn ich immer höre ich mag einfach
prinzipiell nicht die Frage die
Politiker er sagt ja er meint ja nur die
die über die Parteien über die
Landeslisten reingekommen sind ja aber
entschuldige ich gucke mir ja auch eine
Landesliste an und entscheide ob ich die
Partei will oder nicht so ist ja ist ja
nicht so dass ich die Landesliste von
der ich kenne den Spitzenkandidaten
kennen die Abgeordneten auf der Liste
drauf sind und dann kann ich mich
entscheiden ob ich denen meine Stimme
geben oder nicht und im Umkehrschluss
das was du sagst heißt der das alle die
direkt reingekommen sind über direkt man
da das sind die klugen und das sind die
allwissenden das ist stimmt doch nicht
also das Argumentation die über die
Parteien reinkommen nutzen uns nichts
drauf das kann doch dann auch für die
anderen Geld ich ein Vorschlag machen
oder keine Ahnung
ich möchte wegen der Steuersenkung
machen wenn man das Bürgergeld erhöhen
aber die Geringverdiener nicht erhöhen
dann haben wir ein Problem das
lohnabstandsgesetz das bedeutet da
werden wir lieber wenn einer heute 2.400
€ verdient den kann ich nicht 3000 €
geben weil der Mittelstand kann das
nicht finanzieren aber die Steuern
denken dass ich mich 700 Euro Abgaben
habe sondern vielleicht nur 300 Euro und
ich habe 400 Euro mehr in der Tasche
hilft der der arbeitet und die
Unternehmer das werden Vorschlag jetzt
einfach aber da gehen die Politiker
nicht hin weil die Politiker dann Pickel
im Gesicht kriegen wenn sie
Steuersenkung hingehen
lass mich doch nicht so aggressiv und
auch mal polemisch rüberbringen also
die 400 € gerne gebrauchen können und
jetzt noch zum Schluss wenn die
Politiker sagen ja die Geringverdiener
können ja auch zum Jobcenter gehen und
sich Wohnungsgeld erholen und so weiter
ich finde jeder Mensch hat eine würde
die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar
aber die Politiker sagen nicht wie gucke
ich dass du mehr Geld kriegst sondern
wie musst du dann BITTE BITTE und das
kannst nicht sein und das will ich nicht
und vielleicht habe ich das vorher auch
überspannt drüber gebracht aber wenn du
eine Liste willst und das sind 20 drauf
dann findest du zwei gut und 18 scheiße
und du sie die 18 Scheiße mitnehmen
das ist ja ein Thema nur dann lass uns
mal drüber diskutieren über das
bürgerlich damit spätestens eher sagen
nee funktioniert nicht weil das geht ja
auch um Würze
die gleiche übrigens über die
Automobilhersteller das tut mir leid
nur gesagt aber er hat nicht gesagt
machen wird
wie kriegen sie Politik dazu dass das
viele Geld was sie hat in die Zukunft
des Landes investiert statt einfach im
Kopf zu Hause wie machen sie das denn
bitte also ganz im Gegenteil der Reise
kennt was ganz anderes gesagt der Reise
hat nicht mit ihnen ins gleichges blasen
und hat gesagt Deutschland ist scheiße
sondern 30 gesagt ich komme viel rum auf
der Welt und ich finde dass wir eine
gute Nation sind dass wir viele tolle
Sachen machen und dass wir in der Tat in
Deutschland auch Probleme haben die ist
gilt anzugehen aber dieses ewige mies
machen und erzählen dass wir 20 Jahren
über Bildung machen kann Fortschritt wir
machen seit 20 Jahren Infrastruktur
beantworten
das werden wir jetzt leider an dieser
Stelle gar nicht ausdiskutieren können